[Música]
la cuarta ideah condenó al Estado
colombiano por el Exterminio de más de
seis mil líderes y militantes del
partido político de izquierda Unión
patriótica El genocidio se llevó a cabo
desde 1984 y durante más de 20 años en
acciones entre grupos paramilitares
sectores de la política tradicional la
fuerza pública y grupos empresariales
después de más de tres décadas de luchan
las víctimas por fin empiezan a recibir
reparación la conversación sobre este
tema es con ella el Quiroga ella es
senadora por el pacto histórico y
sobreviviente del genocidio de la unión
patriótica Muchas gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros gracias por invitarme
No a usted por ofrecernos su testimonio
y Y la verdad es que antes del fallo el
estado colombiano solamente aceptaba
parcialmente su responsabilidad
reconocía poco más de 200 víctimas y no
a las 6000 que están consignadas y que
ha fallado ahora la idh Por qué y qué
pasará a partir de esta sentencia si yo
creo que
la Corte Interamericana ha hecho
Justicia con las víctimas de la unión
patriótica y el partido político Porque
después de tanto tiempo negando los
hechos que eran evidentes notorios y
públicos la Corte Interamericana
finalmente condena al estado y lo
condena por acción directa de sus
agentes y complicidad de sus agentes con
grupos ilegales no estatales como
empresarios
latifundistas que se unieron todos en un
plan de Exterminio contra los militantes
de la unión patriótica con la intención
de acabar físicamente al partido y
diluir la fuerza política que tenía este
partido que venía en ascenso porque se
creó en un momento en el que en la
Constitución de 1886 y se creó por dos
objetivos el partido político uno era
canalizar todo el descontento y la
inconformidad con la situación que se
vivía actualmente y lo otro era servir
de espacio para la reincorporación de la
guerrilla de las FARC a la vida civil
política social que empezaba con una
tregua de un año ellos mandaron su
delegados a la unión patriótica pero
rápidamente en 1987 se rompió el acuerdo
de paz ellos se regresaron al movimiento
insurgente y la unión patriótica siguió
y siguió cargando con un estigma muy
grande que fue el motor por el cual hubo
veces Exterminio usted nos está contando
el contexto que vivía la up sobre los
años 80 después de entender lo que era y
cómo se llevó a cabo este Exterminio
criminal Dónde está hoy el Movimiento
Político bueno el Movimiento Político
fue exterminado prácticamente
fueron 14 congresistas que se eligieron
en 1986 de los cuales mataron 8
persiguieron la gente a nivel de los 27
departamentos de Colombia de los 32 que
existen fue una persecución atroz no
solamente fueron homicidio fueron
desapariciones forzadas torturas
desplazamiento montaje judiciales fue
algo muy muy duro en este país que no
puede volver a suceder contra ningún
partido político de la ideología que sea
yo creo que esta sentencia lo que no
debe llevar esa hacer esa reflexión aquí
cabemos todos aquí no se puede atacar un
partido político por ideas y es
terminarlo por eso la corte da órdenes
al Estado colombiano para campaña de
desestigmatización campaña de la
Democracia porque este fue un crimen
contra la democracia
contra el estado de derecho en este país
senadora Cómo vivió usted de todo este
episodio de La historia de Colombia
desde su propia historia personal Cuál
es su caso Bueno yo fui concejal por dos
periodos en barrancabermeja centro
petrolero de luchas y allí fundamos el
comité de derechos humanos y por lo
tanto Nos tocó que realmente así
físicamente recoger los muertos de la
unión patriótica en el Magdalena medio
yo tuve que salir de barranca por
resultado de un atentado personal que me
hicieron cuando yo salí en 19
dos ya el genocidio en esa zona se había
consumado ya habían quedado compañeros
en silla de rueda compañeros lisiados
compañeros
asustados porque eso también
asustó el pueblo no solamente a la
organización de la unión patriótica sino
que había mucho temor por la
estigmatización
la exclusión de la gente de la unión
patriótica era palpable no ustedes son
guerrilleros y por eso los están matando
no queremos saber no queremos votar por
ustedes porque no los queremos poner en
la mira Sí una cantidad de de actitudes
que han sido traumáticas y por eso la
corte también
si ordena que se asista la gente
psicológicamente Bueno hay muchas
medidas que se han ordenado entre ellas
por ejemplo un documental para mantener
memoria que se esclarezcan los
asesinatos y también las desapariciones
que usted menciona pero me llama la
atención que el ministro de Justicia
Néstor Osuna dijo que se acatara el
fallo Y que además esta sentencia es la
muestra para reflexionar sobre un país
que fuimos y que no podemos volver a ser
y aquí yo le quiero preguntar sin
embargo sobre la realidad en Colombia
que es de inseguridad y de peligro por
ejemplo para líderes y lideresas
sociales y comunitarios Usted cree que
ha cambiado el país tiene confianza en
la no repetición
la no repetición hay que construirla yo
creo que a partir de esto nosotros
tenemos que reflexionar porque la misma
Corte Interamericana
identificó realmente que la unión
patriótica se volvió aquí se convirtió
en un enemigo del Estado un enemigo
interno Y esa doctrina es una doctrina
que se
concentró en los ejércitos de América
Latina sí a través de la doctrina de
seguridad nacional se creó un enemigo
interno en los estados que había que
combatir Unión patriótica fue uno de los
enemigos internos Pero luego se extendió
no solamente a la insurgencia sino a los
defensores de Derechos Humanos a los
sindicalistas a los líderes sociales los
líderes comunales Y eso es parte de la
doctrina militar
aquí hay que revisar la doctrina aquí el
ministro de defensa y el señor
presidente tienen que este gobierno
revisar esa doctrina que dé garantía de
no repetición esto lo ha afirmado la
fiscalía ahora la Corte Interamericana
lo ha identificado de manera que está el
diagnóstico completo para que se
empiecen a hacer las reformas necesaria
para que esto no vuelva a ocurrir pero
quisiera Resaltar que no solamente este
fallo le sirve a Colombia sino a todo el
continente aquí en el Continente nuestro
americano América Latina Centroamérica
ocurrieron
dictaduras militares
Sí y acabaron con los procesos políticos
de América y no pasó nada este fallo
tendrá un precedente lo siente sienta de
una vez un presidente Para que estos
hechos contra la oposición política en
los estados de América Latina no vuelvan
a suceder senadora Yael Quiroga Yo le
agradezco mucho por su testimonio y por
la reflexión que hace a partir de este
Movimiento Político exterminado
restablecido Y que ahora por fin empieza
a recibir algo de reparación gracias a
usted muchas gracias por invitarme